it's clean up day after Mother Nature  Made her presence loud and clear this  weekend in Las Vegas  so strong it caused a fire near Di and  Grand Canyon  the wind also uprooting several trees  8 news now viewers sending in images  from several parts of the valley the  wind making the dust spread across town  the strip Skyline almost impossible to  see and drivers having a tough time  seeing the distance near Blue Diamond  and Las Vegas Boulevard wind gusts  reached up to 60 miles an hour at times  causing several watches and warnings  Mother Nature giving us another reminder  of just how strong she could be Victoria  Saha 8 News Now